[Música]
las imágenes tienen que ver con la
charla de recomendaciones porque forman
parte de unos temas varios temas que voy
a tocar para tratar de brindar un
contexto que considero necesario que
tengamos quienes deseamos hacer valer
nuestros derechos una sociedad como la
mexicana en donde pues para hacer valer
tus derechos
tienes que gritar los tienes que
conocerlos y tienes que saber cómo a
través de qué canales hacerlos valer
entonces estas dos imágenes tienen
un nombre cada una de ellas se llaman
por cierto que google
qué imagen creen ustedes que sean kiki
la de la de nuestra izquierda o la de
nuestra derecha
la de la derecha y bubu por ende será la
de la izquierda en un 90 ó 90 de un 90
98 por ciento de los hispanoparlantes y
anglosajones aciertan en este sentido
porque pues porque tenemos una conexión
con la imagen y la forma de la lengua de
la boca al pronunciar ciertas palabras
esto es necesario saberlo porque en las
redes sociales eliminamos muchas veces
este este conocimiento más allá de la
comunicación
otra otra cosa quisiera pasar a la
siguiente imagen que es un chat que
tuvimos que tenemos mi esposa y yo no sé
si lo alcanzan a ver es un chat normal
elimine todas las partes ahí esté raras
quiero que vayan al final del chat por
favor una pregunta levanten la mano
quienes crean que el mensaje que me
mandó gabi era un mensaje agresivo o
negativo quiere levantar la mano por
algo positivo
y quien levanta la mano por algo
negativo
ok y ligeramente más personas pensando
que es algo negativo
bueno era algo positivo nada más que
para esta conferencia le mande el
mensaje decía ya vámonos porque nos
íbamos a ir un fin de semana a méxico a
disfrutar de la familia y yo estaba
preparando el material para esta
conferencia y le puse un plantón como
quieras y luego pasó lo que lo que yo
quería ocasionar que les voy a practicar
íbamos en la autopista y gary checa su
whatsapp y me dice yo
qué pasó que te hice yo dije no nada es
para la conferencia o sea a lo que voy
es que el maldito whatsapp no transmite
el 80 por ciento del fenómeno de la
comunicación que es no verbal nos pueden
estar viendo una grabación
posteriormente en like podemos estar
haciendo una transmisión pero no estamos
transmitiendo lo que queremos transmitir
estamos transmitiendo el 20 por ciento y
eso con perdón de ustedes disculpen mi
francés es una comunicación [ __ ]
ese es el efecto de un incluir es otra
parte del contexto que considero
necesario compartir con ustedes para
recibir algunas recomendaciones de
activismo en la era digital
downy y kruger son dos científicos
sociales
que acuñaron lo que yo considero que es
algo muy conocido por el mexicano que es
entendemos pero acompañado siempre es
necesario tener otro para estarse
haciendo uno [ __ ] entonces en el
sujeto y el sujeto es bueno más bien el
sujeto a que el sujeto ver este componer
este sesgo cognitivo que es un sesgo
cognitivo es una forma rimbombante o
científica socialmente de llamarle a los
prejuicios y los prejuicios pensamos
muchas y muchos de nosotros que son
malos que hay que destruirlos hay que
matarlos no son naturales son necesarios
y son lo que nos permite vivir en
sociedad entonces es lo cognitivo donde
incluyen es un prejuicio necesario para
vivir en sociedad y se compone de la
siguiente manera el sujeto es sumamente
competente en su tema en el tema del que
está hablando en una conversación
y ese sujeto comete un error al percibir
de manera errónea valga la redundancia
al sujeto ve el a que es muy competente
supone que el be es igual de competente
que él y por eso está entablando una
conversación sobre un tema en concreto
el bebé es un sujeto diferente él es tan
incompetente sobre el tema
que ignoran su propia incompetencia y
sigue entablando una conversación con el
sujeto que es sumamente competente
entonces el error del sujeto ve es un
error de valoración de sí mismo
y el error del sujeto es un error de
valoración del otro
entonces ambos están pues en una
discúlpenme ahorita en este tiempo de
señas y millennials cerca de negros es
políticamente correcto decirlo
yo sé que son científicos sociales de la
universidad de cornell otro punto que
quiero tratar es el uso y abuso de la
pantalla o el screen time o sea
hace tres años antes del escándalo
cristiano lítica que vino a cambiar todo
el escenario de redes sociales para todo
el juego global tanto en política como
en comercio y que vino a desnudar las
maldades de los modelos neoliberales
este antes de esto las redes sociales
'facebook' hegemónicamente no existiendo
instagram y mucho menos tick tock
pues gobernaban la oferta de
entretenimiento pero
quitándonos o destinando nosotros 2.5
horas de nuestro tiempo diariamente a
estas redes sociales estamos hablando de
2017 2016
este año gracias a instagram en donde
está el 10 por ciento de la población
mundial
vamos a superar las 5 horas de atención
cuando la jornada laboral de trabajo en
el mundo en promedio debería ser en el
mundo civilizado de ocho horas cuántas
de esas horas los consumen las redes
sociales y si a eso le sumamos que todas
las plataformas de redes sociales están
monetizando con nuestra atención es
decir el objetivo es que no despegamos
los ojos de la pantalla nunca
entonces no estamos siendo conscientes
de los problemas de salud que esto
conlleva está confirmado por estudios
recientes que jóvenes de 13 años con
personas de 13 años
y menores de esa edad que destinan
diariamente dos horas
a la pantalla a redes sociales sobre
todo que además están prohibidas para
ellos hasta los 16 años en algunos casos
lastra en las capacidades cognitivas es
decir no aprenden más no pasan de grado
o no deberían de pasar de grado otro
punto que quiero tratar es la nostalgia
y la rotura del tejido social
muchas y muchos de nosotros hemos visto
vivimos incluso tenemos alguna propiedad
lamentamos alguna propiedad o algún
amigo amiga vive en una privada en donde
pues la pluma va a impedir que llegue un
comando armado y haga sus destrozos no
este y que lo único que hace esa pluma
es darnos una falsa idea de estarán
seguros y no se está rompiendo nos están
acabando el tejido social lo mismo que
hace la vivienda vertical
ld efe o sea no salían en vez de vivir
en la calle pues preferimos vivir en
nuestra privada que cada vez tiene
nombres de mayor nivel no sean bosques o
sean de piernas preciosas o sean
referencias al agua que no tenemos
entonces bueno pues el tejido social se
está rompiendo durante el tiempo que he
llevado en este mundo yo recuerdo haber
tomado agua lo cual me hace más viejo
pero más sano gracias son al viejo tengo
41 años soy del 78 maravillosamente lo
digo con mucho orgullo por ciento son
melómanos pongan la atención al 71 es un
gran gran año entonces creo que ahorita
a diferencia de antes gracias a las
redes hemos dejado de salir y
enjuiciamos glorificamos y matamos a la
gente en redes sociales no queremos
formar parte del problema pero si
decimos
de piloto mujer [ __ ] que ibas armando
y perdió su trabajo en las redes
yo
jutsu problema del iut software que es
una maravilla y se recomiendo mucho
ahora si vamos a pasar a las
recomendaciones las recomendaciones son
ocho recomendaciones en concreto y por
qué por qué digo porque me invitaron a
hacer las recomendaciones en el mundo
digital para activistas porque para
activistas si yo no me considera un
activista y esto lo quiero aclarar yo he
luchado por lo que considero que es
y algo de sentido común que debería de
ser de sentido común y no se hace como
tener este frente a los peatones
barras como para amarrar a los caballos
en cualquier parte de la ciudad como
tener semáforos que no cumplen con la
norma como tener muchas cosas y esto
este activismo pues lo hago porque me
dedico a los redes sociales junto con mi
esposa que está aquí presente con
nuestra empresa desde hace más de ocho
años y porque gracias a esas a ir a ese
dedicarnos nos hemos dado cuenta de todo
este contexto que yo les comparto
entonces más allá de algoritmos más allá
de esta es la mejor hora para que yo te
recomiendo tres minutos en el vídeo y
ponte así ellas las hay acá eso
realmente no tiene importancia lo que
tiene importancia es uno hacer compasión
las cosas a mí me hablaron el día no sé
quién haya visto levanten la mano por
favor para darme una idea si alguien
ubica el vídeo de las palmeras de la
treviño aquí en este recinto
ante la mano poca gente ok les platico
iban a cortar unas palmeras de 60 años
de más de 60 años en la treviño entonces
un amigo me marco un conocido de
facebook me marco y juntos empezamos a
transmitir ya estaban los bomberos
listos para luchar las otras dos se
aventaron dos palmeras mil o sea
históricas y logramos impedir el corte
de esas palmeras gracias a un a varios
vídeos
yo transmitido en vivo muchas veces y
muchas veces han sido reproducciones muy
cortas obviamente se siente muy padre
que tengas muchas traducciones pero el
objetivo no es ese porque si no andaría
yo cazando y cazando temas por doquier y
ese no es el punto
entonces el primer punto es hacer las
cosas con pasión no vivo por ahí no está
mi oficina por ahí no tengo intereses
por ahí pero [ __ ] es mi ciudad y son
símbolos de nuestra ciudad como las
palmeras el segundo factor que es
transmitir la indignación el segundo
factor
y bueno perdón junto con este primer es
la primera recomendación de hacer las
cosas con pasión viene una una nota al
calce que es que este año me ha
contactado mucha más gente para
enarbolar alguna causa pero me parece
sumamente irresponsable de mi parte por
medio de una lectura nada más de unos
datos supuestos de una información que
puede ser errónea el hecho de que yo
comparta algo
la segunda recomendación es algo que no
hacemos y que no hacen los políticos que
no hacemos nosotros desde que existe el
coche parece que nacimos en el carro le
tenemos miedo a caminar sobre todo en la
provincia no sé cabrona disculpen
ustedes el latín que no nos podamos
estacionar exactamente la puerta del
museo arocena porque tienen cerrado
estos saben entonces tenemos que caminar
tenemos que caminar es uno de los cinco
hábitos que ubican a los españoles como
a los más longevos del planeta con un
promedio de 82 años superando por 4 el
promedio de mexico para mujeres es de 78
y para varones que es de 76 años de edad
hagan cuentas y empiecen a caminar
caminar nos permite tener
los pies en la tierra caminar nos
permite hablar con la gente conocer a la
gente y hacerlo rutinariamente
diariamente por los mismos lugares tener
una rutina nos permite conocer también
el barrio y conocer de lo que hablamos
las carencias yo no puedo decir que
alguna alcantarilla está caída si no la
he visto o que el municipio tiene un
problema si no he visto ese problema
repetidamente yo yo no puedo enarbolar
una causa por la que no he conocido de
mis con mis ojos vayan entonces antes de
enarbolar una causa que se encuentra al
otro lado del mundo que si a mí me
preocupa como usted es el cambio
climático por mucho y por el simple
hecho de ser un serial o generación x
tardía sin tener los hijos ya soy
contaminante pero hago crearme todo lo
posible por por no contaminar y no trato
de no perder el tiempo en andar
cuestionando a que el papá que mató a su
hijo en timbuctú ayer no porque además
cuido mucho lo que el algoritmo me
ofrece lo que escucho lo que me meto
aquí en los ojos que debe ser contenido
positivo que debe ser contenido
enriquecedor la tercera recomendación es
no estoy de acuerdo con mis antes
antecesores conocerse a uno mismo
conócete a ti mismo y dile no al bol y
activista que enarbola toda causa por
masa que la que ésta sea no sé si tengan
ustedes o conozcan ustedes alguna
persona que caray es activista de todo
de todo o sea es vegano y es carnívoro
al mismo tiempo es animalista y hasta
ahora no he juego todas las causas las
conoce y no se dedica a conocerse
primero uno mismo yo estoy de acuerdo
que es necesario conocer los derechos
y luego hacerlos respetar hacerlos valer
pero antes de tener los pantalones para
decir que conozco mis derechos y que los
hago valer estaría muy muy muy muy bien
hacer un trabajo de introspección y
decir cómo ando yo
esto me molesta a mí mucho que molestan
y mucho que me para el tránsito pero yo
iba a alta velocidad y ahora sí voy a
sacar al mexicano clásico que le va a
dar mordida o que lo va a maltratar
o voy a aceptar que estoy mal y voy a
hacer las cosas bien
4 amplifica tus acciones materiales a
través de las redes sociales o sea
muévete me ha pasado infinidad de veces
que me mandan un mensaje una persona un
desconocido o conocido oye sólo
necesitas necesito que me ayudes por
favor porque mira me detuvieron ayer y
esto no se vale y el alcoholímetro o la
vuelta o la e en algunos casos es justo
me parece en algunos no no lo sé pero yo
lo que sí creo es que si seguimos
dependiendo de un camino para hacer lo
que a nosotros nos corresponde estamos
mal
entonces si quieren ser activistas
salgan utilicen las herramientas legales
y válidas de resistencia civil
esta presión se puede hacer presión yo
les aseguro ustedes que una persona una
persona afuera de la presidencia
municipal o del palacio del gobierno
transmitiendo correctamente diciendo que
no se va a retirar de ahí hasta que su
demanda no sea cumplida pesa pesa porque
pesa porque el miedo es correspondiente
al peso 5 y aquí entramos en una triada
las 5 las 6 y las 7 son una tira de
recomendaciones esta es la primera
meditar diariamente antes de juzgar al
otro debemos conocernos bien a nosotros
mismos
esta es una aplicación yo medito hace
cerca de dos años en noviembre 10
voy a cumplir dos años de meditar
diariamente excepto por un día que se me
pasó pero la verdad no me clavo tanto sé
que hacerlo diariamente como cualquier
otra actividad va a llevarme bombardeen
porque hay dos caminos el camino difícil
entonces el largo
disciplina rutina perseverancia práctica
experiencia el camino fácil puede que
llegue pero vas a ser el primero y lo
peor es que puede que no llegues
entonces meditar diariamente yo utilizo
esta aplicación que se llama head space
está rankeada en el número dos a nivel
mundial
la número uno se llama ko o calma en
español este como todas las aplicaciones
gratuitas tú eres el y es gratuita tú
eres el producto entonces hay que pagar
por ella pero pues por esta aplicación
pagas lo que pagas por una sesión y
media de meditación en grupo entonces yo
lo hago todos los días en casa y me ha
cambiado la vida
2 practica regularmente un deporte el
que quieras no es no los mexicanos no
tenemos suficiente con que nos digan por
televisión de repente el gobierno 30
minutos por lo menos 3 veces a la semana
no tenemos somos el primer lugar en
tragar cocacola en obesidad necesitamos
cuatro días a la semana una hora mínimo
de actividad metabólica o sea tenemos
que movernos porque además somos ejemplo
del futuro o somos el futuro en el peor
de los casos de nuestro país entonces
hacer deporte es uno de los de los actos
de amor más importantes de amor propio
que he hecho para mí yo primero lo hice
para verme bien estaba a llorar me
faltaba una tercera parte de la tríada
la primera es la meditación la segunda
es el deporte y lo hacía para verme bien
no para estar bien no para vivir bien no
para estar sano
la tercera parte que es acudir a terapia
es muy necesario acudir a terapia este
puente yo yo considero que éste fue
o nunca y lo que entonces esté recibir
el acompañamiento de un profesional de
la psicología es tan necesario como ir
al dentista o sea en mi vida la verdad
es mejor después de la terapia ha sido
un antes y un después el proceso
terapéutico duró cinco años cuatro meses
duró más que mi carrera ciertamente nada
más que una maestría que tengo
inconclusa sobre gestión pública
aplicada porque aunque ustedes no lo
crean
fui burócrata estuve en gobierno
entonces pues por eso los conozco a los
cabrones porque estuve
la 8 se realiza en tus objetivos no
podemos cambiar mucho
si bien no podemos evitar
que
se cometan crímenes de lesa humanidad de
corea del norte que donald trump este as
avivando el fuego en contra de los
mexicanos
tengamos posturas sobre todo y sobre
todas las cosas sobre el aborto sobre el
derecho a la mujer sobre todo ahora los
hombres estamos así que no se los damos
por los derechos de las mujeres y es
cuando más tenemos que callar entonces
seamos realistas realistas en nuestros
objetivos no se puede cambiar el mundo
aceptemos el hecho de que habrá cosas
que no podremos mejorar o resolver y de
que lastimar hemos hemos ajenos de qué
arriesgaremos la fama personal la vida o
peor aún considero la libertad
dependiendo si el caso es necesario para
poder tomar
decisiones futuras yo me pregunto si
vale la pena el riesgo yo creo que sí sí
vale la pena el riesgo muchas gracias
por su atención
[Aplausos]